제가 오늘은
bsm 건축가 사무소에서 설계한
건물들을 좀 소개해 드리려고 합니다
일단
bsn이 많은 분들이 부동산
중개법이만 있다라고 생각을 하시는데
bsm 건축사 사무소랑 bsm
종합건설이 있습니다 그래서 저희가
중계 그리고 설계 공사까지 맡아서
하고 있고요 그리고 매매 관련된
정과정을
통키로 맞춰서 도와드리고 있습니다
bsn 건축사사무소는 주로 강남 거
위주로
리모델링이나 신축을 진행을 했었고
총
58건의 설계를 진행을 했습니다
그래서 오늘 영상은 제 bsm 건축사
사무소에서 설계한 신축 사례랑
리모델링 사례 두 건씩을 소개해
드리도록 하겠습니다 지금 있는이 건물
같은 경우에는
강남구 역삼동에 위치한 건물입니다
그래서 돼지가 162평이고
연면적이 약 300평 정도
건물이구요 그리고 지하 1층에 지상
4층 규모의 건물입니다 그래서이
건물은 원래 상가주택 건물이었는데
이거를 근린생활시설로 용도변경을
했습니다 주택을 용도 변경할 때는
보통 이제 내력벽 철거 때문에 비용이
좀 많이 발생되는 부분이 있는데이
건물 같은 경우에는 내력벽 철거를
최소화해서 살릴 수 있는 건 최대한
살려 가지고 비용을 좀 아낀 그런
사례라고 보시면 될 것 같고요 그리고
외관은 지금 보시는 거와 같이
타공판을 설치해서 좀 깔끔한 이미지를
연출을 했습니다 그래서 지금이 건물
같은 경우에는 우리가 설계한 거 중에
강남구 아름다운 건축상을 수상한 그런
건물입니다 안에도 한번 좀 들어가서
보도록 하겠습니다 가시죠
[박수]
리모델링 전 상가주택일 때 임대료는
약 900만원이 안 됐지만
리모델링 후에 임대료는
약 3배가 넘게
임대가 맞춰졌습니다
매입가는 97억에 매입해서
약 10억원 비용을 들여서
리모델링을 한 뒤에
시세가 최소 160억원 이상이 될
것으로 예상이 됩니다 그래서이 사례는
최소 비용으로 최대의 효과를 낸 그런
사례라고 보시면 될 것 같습니다
외관은 롱브릭으로 모던하게 마감을
하였고
용적률이 남아 있어
리모델링을 하면서 한계충을
증축하였습니다 그리고 도로사선 받은
부분은 반듯하게 펴서 공간 활용을
최대한으로 하였고
엘리베이터도 신규로 설치해서 수익성을
극대화하였습니다
리모델링 전 임대료는 약 1000만원
정도 나왔는데
리모델링 후에 임대수익은
약 3배가 넘게
임대가 맞춰졌습니다
주차장 부지를 약 60억원의 매입한
뒤에 쇼룸 및 4억 용도로
신축하였습니다 전면 파사드는 여러가지
볼륨의 커튼을 입면이 각각의 쇼
윈도우로 보이실 수 있는 디자인
컨셉으로 계획하였습니다
측면 계단식 부분에
메쉬브한 볼륨은 수직 커튼월로
답답함을 해소하였고 유리 내부로
비춰지는 계단 구조물을 디자인 요소로
활용하였습니다
[음악]
이 부지를 약 60억원의 매입해서
신축한이 건물의 현재 시세는 최소
150억 이상이 될 것으로 예상이
됩니다
[음악]
준공업지역의 대지가 67평인 낡은
빌딩을
약 60억원의 매입해서
멸실 후에
지하 2층 지상 8층 규모로 신축을
하였습니다
대지면적은 크지 않지만 건물 층수가
있다보니
규모가 꽤 있어 보입니다
창을 아치형으로 만들어서 포인트를
주었고 건물 전체적으로
고급스러운 느낌을 줍니다
신축적인 임대료는 약 500만원에서
6배 이상 상승하였고 건물 시세도
최소 130억원 이상이 될 것으로
예상이 됩니다네 이상으로 bsm
건축사사무소에서 설계했던 사례들을
소개해드렸습니다
혹시 설계에 대해서 궁금하신 점이
있다면
유튜브 설명란에 저희가 양식을 좀
남겨놨는데 거기에 양식을 좀 적어
주시면 저희가
연락을 드려서 상담을 도와드리도록
하겠습니다 그래서 오늘 영상 여기까지
하고요
다음 시간에 뵙도록 하겠습니다
감사합니다
[음악]